farming is hard work it's a labor of
love that requires dedication resilience
and a deep connection to the land it
always has been and it always will be
the sun rises the seasons change and the
work never stops but that doesn't mean
we can't look for ways to work smarter
not harder with the advancements in
technology we have more tools at our
disposal than ever before especially
when it comes to something as important
as irrigation water is the lifeblood of
any farm and efficient irrigation can
make all the difference that's why I'm
excited to talk to you about solar
irrigation systems these Innovative
systems harness the power of the sun to
provide a reliable water source for your
crops these systems use the power of the
sun to keep your crops watered saving
you money and helping the environment at
the same time it's a win-win situation
for both your farm and the planet in
this guide we'll walk through the
process of installing a solar irrigation
system step by step from selecting the
right components to setting up the
system we've got you covered don't don't
worry it's not as complicated as you
might think with clear instructions and
a bit of patience you'll be able to set
up your system in no time with a little
bit of elbow grease and some basic tools
you'll be able to install a system that
will make your life easier and your farm
more
sustainable imagine the Peace of Mind
knowing your crops are getting the water
they need even on the hottest days
speaking of sustainable using the sun to
water your crops just makes sense it's a
natural renewable energy source that's
always available it's a clean renewable
energy source that's available to all of
us and it's not just about saving money
it's about doing our part to protect the
environment for future generations and
with the cost of traditional energy
sources on the rise solar irrigation is
becoming more and more costeffective
every day the initial investment pays
off quickly as you start to see savings
on your energy bills whether you're a
seasoned farmer or just starting out
this guide will give you the knowledge
and confidence you need to install your
own solar irrigation system it's a
journey worth taking and we're here to
help you every step of the way so let's
roll up our sleeves get a little dirt
under our fingernails and get started
together we can make farming more
sustainable and efficient one solar
panel at a time before we jump into the
installation process let's make sure you
have all the necessary tools and
equipment proper preparation is key to a
successful and efficient setup just like
any job having the right gear on hand
will make the whole process smoother and
more enjoyable it can save you time
reduce frustration and ensure that your
system works as intended from the get-go
here's a detailed rundown of what you'll
need to gather before you start first
and foremost you'll need solar panels
these are the heart of the system
converting sunlight into electricity to
power the pump the size and number of
panels you need will depend on the size
of your irrigation system and the amount
of sunlight you get in your area make
sure to do a bit of research or consult
with a professional to determine the
optimal setup for your specific needs
remember the efficiency of your solar
panels can vary based on their placement
and the angle at which they are
installed proper positioning can
significantly impact the amount of
energy they generate next up you'll need
a solar powered pump this pump will draw
water from your Source whether it's a
well lake or Pond and deliver it to your
crops there are two main types of solar
pumps surface pumps and submersible
pumps each has its own advantages and is
suited for different situations surface
pumps are less expensive and easier to
install but they're not as efficient for
deep Wells they are ideal for shallow
water sources and can be a
cost-effective solution for many small
to medium-sized Farms submersible pumps
on the other hand are more efficient for
deep Wells but they're more expensive
and a bit more complicated to install
they are designed to be placed
underwater and can handle higher water
pressure making them suitable for larger
or deeper water sources you may also
want to consider a battery for your
system a battery will store excess
energy generated by the solar panels
allowing you to irrigate your crops even
when the sun isn't shining this is
especially useful in areas with cloudy
weather or if you need to irrigate at
night having a reliable battery backup
can ensure that your irrigation system
remains operational regardless of the
weather conditions of course you'll need
piping or a drip irrigation system to
distribute the water to your crops the
type of piping you choose will depend on
your specific needs and the layout of
your farm drip irrigation systems are
highly efficient and can help conserve
water by delivering it directly to the
roots of your plants this method reduces
Water waste and ensures that your crops
get the moisture they need and don't
forget about mounting brackets to
securely attach those solar panels
you'll want to choose brackets that are
sturdy and can withstand the elements
properly mounted solar panels will not
only last longer but will also perform
better as they will be less likely to
shift or get damaged by wind and weather
last but not least you'll need some
basic tools such as wrenches screws pipe
connectors and a voltmeter having these
tools on hand will make the installation
process much easier make sure to double
check your toolkit before you start so
you don't have to stop Midway to hunt
for a missing tool a well prepared tool
kit can save you a lot of time and
hassle with all these supplies gathered
you're now ready to move on to the
installation phase proper preparation
will set you up for success and ensure
that your solar irrigation system runs
smoothly and efficiently so take your
time to gather everything you need and
you'll be well on your way to a
sustainable and efficient irrigation
system for your garden or Farm now that
you have all your gear it's time to find
the perfect spot for your solar
irrigation system choosing the right
location is crucial for maximizing the
efficiency of your system and ensuring
its longevity the most important factor
to consider is sunlight exposure your
solar panels need to be in a spot that
receives direct sunlight for as many
hours of the day as as possible avoid
areas that are shaded by trees buildings
or other obstructions the more sunlight
your panels receive the more energy
they'll generate and the more
efficiently your system will operate
proximity to your water source is
another important consideration the
closer your pump is to the Water Source
the less energy it will require to draw
water this means you can get away with
using smaller less expensive solar
panels in a smaller pump with your
location selected it's time to start
setting up your solar panels This is a
critical step as the positioning of your
panels directly impacts their energy
production first you'll need to securely
Mount the panels using the brackets you
purchased make sure the brackets are
rated for your panel size and weight and
can withstand your local wind conditions
you'll want to angle the panels towards
the south or north if you're in the
southern hemisphere to maximize their
exposure to sunlight throughout the day
the ideal angle will vary depending on
your latitude once the panels are
mounted it's time to to wire them
together solar panels are typically
wired in series or parallel or a
combination of both series wiring
increases the voltage while parallel
wiring increases the current the best
wiring configuration for your system
will depend on the specific requirements
of your pump and the size of your solar
array section five installing your solar
pump with your solar panels soaking up
the sun it's time to install the
Workhorse of your system the solar pump
this pump will be responsible for moving
water from your source to to where you
need it making it a crucial component of
your setup if you're using a surface
pump find a level solid base near your
water source this ensures that the pump
operates efficiently and reduces the
risk of damage or malfunction secure the
pump to the base using bolts or straps
ensuring it's stable and won't topple
over stability is key to maintaining the
longevity and performance of your pump
now if you're using a submersible pump
carefully lower it into your well or
water source using the attached cable
take your time to avoid any damage to
the pump or cables make sure the cables
are secure and won't get tangled proper
cable management is essential to prevent
any operational issues or hazards next
connect the pump to your water source
using the appropriate piping this step
is crucial for ensuring that water flows
smoothly and efficiently through your
system make sure you use piping that's
compatible with your pump and rated for
the pressure and flow rate of your
system using the right materials will
help prevent leaks and other issues seal
all connections tightly to prevent leaks
leaks can lead to water loss and reduced
efficiency so take care to ensure
everything is sealed properly finally
connect the pump to your solar panels or
battery Bank depending on your system
configuration this connection is what
powers your pump so make sure it's done
correctly double check all connections
to ensure they're secure and properly
insulated to prevent electrical shorts
safety is Paramount so take the time to
verify everything is in order section
six connecting the irrigation system now
it's time to connect the final piece of
the puzzle the irrigation system this is
where your hard work pays off as you'll
soon be delivering water directly to
your thirsty crops if you're using a
drip irrigation system lay out the drip
lines along your rows of plants ensuring
each plant has a dedicated emitter bury
the lines a few inches below the soil
surface to minimize evaporation if
you're using traditional piping connect
connect the pipes to the pump outlet and
run them to your Fields install valves
at strategic points in your irrigation
system to control the flow of water to
different sections of your farm this
will allow you to customize your
watering schedule based on the specific
needs of your crops section seven
testing your new solar irrigation system
with everything connected it's time for
the Moment of Truth testing your new
solar irrigation system this is where
you get to see all your hard work come
to fruition start by checking all
connections once one last time to ensure
they're tight and secure then switch on
the pump and observe the flow of water
the water pressure should be consistent
and strong enough to reach the furthest
points of your irrigation system if you
notice any leaks immediately turn off
the pump and repair the connections it's
better to catch and fix leaks early on
before they can cause any damage once
you're satisfied that everything is
working correctly you can start
irrigating your crops Section 8
maintaining your solar irrigation system
congratulations you've you've
successfully installed a solar
irrigation system now to keep it running
smoothly for years to come you'll need
to perform some regular maintenance the
most important maintenance task is
keeping your solar panels clean dust
dirt and debris can accumulate on the
panel's surface reducing their
efficiency wipe down the panels
regularly with a soft cloth or a hose to
remove any buildup you'll also want to
inspect your pump and piping
periodically for any signs of wear and
tear replace any damaged components
immediately to prevent leaks or other
issues check the pump's oil level
regularly and top it off as needed
section nine embrace the future of
farming with solar irrigation installing
a solar irrigation system is an
investment in the future of your farm
and the planet by harnessing the power
of the sun you're reducing your Reliance
on fossil fuels saving money on energy
costs and ensuring a consistent water
supply for your crops but the benefits
of solar irrigation extend beyond your
farm by adopting this sustainable Tech
technology you're contributing to a
cleaner healthier environment for
everyone you're reducing greenhouse gas
emissions conserving water and promoting
a more sustainable future for
agriculture so take pride in your
decision to go solar and spread the word
to other farmers in your community
together we can create a more
sustainable and resilient agricultural
system for generations to come